i was eating breakfast i was about to go
to school and my sister
was like oh my god i was like what what
happened
she was like you just got nominated for
a juno and i was like sweet like
what category um my label didn't tell me
which ones they like submitted me for so
i had no idea
she was like pop out of the years
it's a little weird it's all there's
like a bit of
um imposter syndrome almost because i'm
like
how am i in the category with this guy
like this doesn't make sense
um you know like this was like he was
like he's my idol growing up he really
was
uh so it's really crazy for me
of course i'm very grateful it's awesome
incredible um but
it's yeah it's overall a little weird
i'm i'm happy to be there though
i'm johnny i know hi i'm madison
maddie did i do a cameo message for you
well it's nice to meet you in real life
maddie
it's always much more scary when you
were filming for the record i was
that's like i don't care like i can
perform in front of
thousand people 20 000 people
like doesn't matter acting i get so
nervous start sweating
shaking everything so it was
it was really cool it was really really
fun to be a part of it i did start
acting actually before
i had ever really done much in
in like the mainstream music world i
started acting i think when i was 11
just because i was too young to do
anything in music really no labels were
looking at me
i was putting out singles but not much
traction like just things like that
i just wanted to be in the entertainment
industry and i
approached it from all sides so i did
some voice acting and some
live action acting so i had a little bit
of
like the prerequisite but not much
just to like work with just to like
watch them in the studio
i really just want to see what kanye
west is like in the studio
i would love to know what his process is
because it
this the stuff that he makes the stuff
he used to make as well
it's just so different i'd love to know
how he how he keeps it fresh
i would i would love to uh to tap into
his brain
just just see how it works
you